hello my name but francoderole you
are in tunisia is obsessed with the
tahrir mine where quays are beginning to
know gmo reapers read 15 euro
deputies actually took part in the european
union's electoral observation mission
they had come to make sure  that the
very first free election of the
Arab spring and chickens
democratically and in a fair way
first of all and it is fundamental
the european union only comes to observe
elections if it has been
formally invited by the country
concerned our presence gives  credit
show our immense interest and then
I believe gives them even more
pride
then an exploratory mission
visits the country several months before
the election and determines if the mission
is useful according to three criteria democratic health
respect for human
rights  man
the added value of the mission for the
electoral process in tunisia it was
the mep michael galère who led
the mission
it was made up of 180 observers,
including 66 long-term observers who spent
several weeks in the country
a delegation of fifteen MEPs took
part
led by the MEP gabriele
albertini
the purpose of the mission is to observe that
the rules of the game are respected
observers do not play a concrete role
on the spot their mandate consists only of
observation but their presence is crucial
for the smooth running of the election
often the elections are the first
democratically organized for a
long time the participation is huge
and the infrastructures sometimes ill-
prepared after training  on their
arrival to better understand the species of the
future of the country
they are then dispersed between
different constituencies to
observe the electoral campaign and then the
ballot they sometimes have to go
to very remote places
but the work does not stop once
that the election is over
then remains to assess the counting  nt
and counting of the votes
electoral disputes including
invalid ballots and other irregularities
within 48 hours of the ballot
an initial assessment is presented by
the Swiss head of mission were the
inouk arrested but which
also crystallizes it is short but to  close to
the highway cool or fun and what
follows is a final report and
recommendations
since 1993 the european union has carried out
more than 110 observation missions with
sometimes disappointing results in
pakistan for example in 2008 the report
of mission was clearly unfavorable
and highlighted irregularities
during the poll in sudan in 2015 under
the mandates of the mission of
reservations had to because of
ethnic tensions in the south of the country
sometimes it is the very legitimacy of a
mission which pose problems as in
Mexico in 2006 even if the mission and
the Mexican federal electoral institute
had returned favorable conclusions
on the conduct of the elections  ions
the opposition denounced a gigantic fraud
ahah